Es war 2013. Ich konnte um
4 Uhr morgens noch nicht schlafen.
Da fiel mir ein,
dass in der Schweiz etwas fehlt:
Unterhaltung in Schweizerdeutsch.
Ich dachte,
ich fange einfach mal an,
dann explodierte es förmlich.
Auf Swissmeme
habe ich 500'000 Follower.
Auf Swissmeme.tv
habe ich über 200'000 Follower.
Auf Zekisworld
Ich habe einen YouTube-Account
mit knapp 90'000 Followern.
Das summiert sich alles.
Wenn man die Zahlen zusammenzählt,
kommt man auf 1,2 Mio. Follower.
* Rockmusik: "Children of
the Revolution" von T. Rex *
Wir als Content-Creators oder
Influencer, wie man uns nennt,
machen das Ganze etwas menschlicher.
Genau das wollen Menschen:
Sie wollen reale Gesichter
hinter den Kulissen.
Im Grossen und Ganzen empfand ich es
bisher nur als positiv.
* Rockmusik: "Children of
the Revolution" von T. Rex *
Fuck them, dude!
Do you laugh? You lose.
Hallo, meine Lieben,
willkommen zu meinem neuen Video.
Die Welt der Influencer
ist das Internet.
Sie filmen und fotografieren
sich selbst,
posten die Bilder
auf den Social Media Plattformen
und verdienen damit Geld - viel Geld.
Geschätzte 5 bis 10 Mrd. $
werden Influencer
alleine in diesem Jahr umsetzen.
Die neuen Stars sind nicht mehr
Berühmtheiten aus Musik und Film -
sondern ganz normale Menschen.
Ihre Fans sind Follower.
Je grösser die Gefolgschaft,
umso wertvoller ein Post.
Mein Name ist Julia Graf.
Ich bin YouTuberin, Content-Creator
und Social-Media-Persönlichkeit.
Man nennt uns auch Influencer.
Es gibt Leute, die nur über Food
oder nur über Fashion posten.
Ich versuche, alles zu verbinden,
was mir gerade Spass macht.
Ich schiesse ein Foto, das ich
nachher auf Instagram poste.
Ich tagge einen Brand, der selbst
einen Instagram-Account besitzt.
Weil ich diese Impressionen
mit meinen Follower teile,
erhalte ich Geld.
In den USA verdienen die
erfolgreichsten Stars im Internet
für eine einzige Empfehlung,
einen einzigen Post,
bis zu mehreren 100'000 $.
It's my own personal Krave!
Junge Kundschaft wird nicht mehr
über klassische Werbung erreicht,
stattdessen setzen Unternehmen
auf Influencer, die mit Empfehlungen
das Kaufverhalten ihrer Follower
beeinflussen.
Das sind die zwei Gerüche ...
Was also ist Influencer Marketing?
Schamlose Schleichwerbung?
Die neueste, effiziente
Strategie der Werbeindustrie?
Sind Follower nichts anderes
als unkritische Konsumenten,
blosse Empfänger
von Werbebotschaften?
Oder ist alles nur ein Hype,
ein Phänomen unserer Zeit?
Für andere sieht es vielleicht
nicht aus, als würden wir arbeiten,
weil wir uns so verkaufen,
so präsentieren,
als wäre es der Traum,
als würde alles mit null Effort
entstehen, aber es ist nicht so.
Es steckt viel Planung dahinter.
Oftmals muss ich Sachen tun,
obwohl es z.B. megakalt ist,
nur weil wir jetzt
dieses Bild brauchen.
Dann muss ich es trotzdem tun,
auch wenn Location und Temperatur
nicht perfekt sind.
Ich muss lächeln und so tun,
als wäre alles super.
Der Basler Zeki Bulgurcu
ist einer der umtriebigsten
Instagramer der Deutschschweiz.
Zeki arbeitet
als Social Media Manager
bei einem Schweizer Privatsender.
Auf seinen eigenen Accounts folgen
ihm über 1,2 Mio. junge Menschen.
Das sind mehr als
die täglich verteilten Exemplare
der grössten Schweizer Gratiszeitung.
Ich stamme ursprünglich
aus der Türkei.
Mit drei Jahren
kam ich in die Schweiz.
Mittlerweile bin ich
seit über 25 Jahren in der Schweiz.
Mir gefällt es in der Schweiz.
Mittlerweile beherrsche ich meine
eigene Muttersprache weniger gut
als Schweizerdeutsch.
Superkarte? Nein, ich brauche
keine Karte, um super zu sein.
Keine Quittung, kann es
nicht von den Steuern abziehen.
4 Fr. kostet es?
Aber ich habe nur 10 Fr.
Adieu.
Die Quittung schenke ich Ihnen.
Ich machte meine Lehre
im Detailhandel.
Ich war ziemlich unzufrieden,
es war wie in einem Hamsterrad.
Privat unterhielt ich
hobbymässig gerne Leute,
brachte Leute zum Lachen.
Ich fragte mich,
was ich unternehmen muss,
um mehr Leute erreichen zu können.
So kam ich auf Swissmeme.
Ich startete den Account,
begann, Bilder und Videos zu posten.
So wurden es immer mehr und mehr.
David, schau nicht in den Spiegel,
sonst versaust du dir den Tag!
Was schreibt Mark?
"Hab reingeschaut."
Ja, in dein hässliches Gesicht.
Swissmeme
ist eigentlich so entstanden:
Bevor das Ganze überhaupt losging,
war ich ständig auf der Suche
nach Witzen in Schweizerdeutsch,
Witze in Schweizerdeutsch,
die auch Jugendliche ansprechen.
Ich dachte,
ich mache das jetzt einfach mal.
Ein Stück weit ist das
völlig spontan entstanden,
weil ich um 4 Uhr morgens
nicht schlafen konnte.
Dann postete ich einfach mal
ein Bild in Schweizerdeutsch.
Darauf schaukelte sich die Sache
hoch, Leute wurden aufmerksam,
weil ich in der Schweiz
der Erste war, der das tat.
Nach fünf Jahren zähle ich
mittlerweile 1,2 Mio. Follower.
Grüezi, ich hätte gerne
ein Sandwich Leccese.
Wollen Sie es kalt oder warm?
Gerne warm, aber nur ein bisschen.
Willst du ein Säckchen?
- Nein, ist gut. Danke.
Kennst du ihn?
Ja, sicher!
Wer kennt ihn schon nicht?
Wer ist er?
- Zeki!
Er macht brutal
Instagram-Videos und so.
Darüber lache ich mich immer kaputt.
Ja, voll!
Was findest du lustig?
Alles an ihm: Sein Auftreten,
was er so sagt, das stimmt alles.
Es ist wirklich
sehr realitätsbezogen.
Er hat es wirklich voll drauf.
Alles klar?
- Ja. Und bei dir?
Ich sah, wie du mich
von Weitem fotografiert hast.
Ja, das habe ich.
Willst du ein Foto machen?
Oder ein Selfie? Also, komm!
Woher kennst du ihn?
Von Instagram, Facebook,
von Social Media.
Findest du ihn cool?
- Ja, er ist ein korrekter Typ.
Wenn ich in die Stadt gehe,
werde ich recht oft für
Selfies und Smalltalk angehalten.
Und ich tue das auch gerne,
für mich ist das kein Problem.
Problematisch wird es,
wenn ich ein Restaurant besuche,
und dann fünf Jugendliche mit ihren
Handys um meinen Tisch stehen
und ein Foto von mir wollen.
Da beginnt es, unangenehm zu werden.
Wollen wir Fotos machen?
- Sehr gut!
Was lauft so?
- He, geile Siech!
Tschau! Alles klar?
- Machen wir ein Foto?
Ja, kein Problem.
Geile Siech, tschau! Mach's gut!
Eine ganz andere Zielgruppe
hat Julia Graf im Visier.
Die studierte
Politikwissenschaftlerin
hat ihr Hobby zum Beruf gemacht.
Ich mache seit 2008
Videos auf YouTube
über das Thema Beauty,
Lifestyle, Gesundheit,
ab und zu auch Kochvideos,
einfach so verschiedene Themen.
2008 begann ich das als Hobby.
Nie hätte ich gedacht,
dass daraus ein Business,
ein Geschäft daraus entstehen würde.
Ich konnte es dann zu meinem Beruf
machen, was natürlich supertoll ist.
Julia Graf hat inzwischen
800'000 Abonnentinnen und Abonnenten
und gehört damit zu den erfolg-
reichsten YouTubern der Schweiz.
Diese Videos filme ich
in meinem eigenen Heimstudio,
das ich mir selbst aufgebaut habe.
Ich mache wirklich alles selbst.
Ich filme, schiesse Bilder,
benutze ein Schnittprogramm.
All das habe ich mir
selbst beigebracht.
Am Abend und am Wochenende
arbeitete ich daran.
Ich stellte das
dann auf YouTube online,
um zu sehen, was passiert.
Von Anfang an lief es
eigentlich relativ gut.
Und die Zuschauer gaben mir
sofort Feedback, ihre Kommentare.
Das hat mich natürlich
immer angespornt, weiterzumachen.
Als der Kanal dann grösser wurde,
als auch Firmen
darauf aufmerksam wurden,
merkten die plötzlich:
"Aha, da sind Leute auf YouTube,
die Produkte zeigen
oder Videos von sich selbst machen."
Dann fing es damit an,
dass ich anfangs von eher kleineren
Firmen angeschrieben wurde.
Das waren Indie-Brands,
weil die kein Budget hatten, um
traditionelle Werbung zu betreiben.
Dafür erhielt ich z.B. ein paar
Lidschatten gratis zur Verfügung.
Erst in den letzten paar Jahren
wurde es zu einem grossen Geschäft,
weil dann die grossen Firmen,
die wirklich bekannten Marken,
auch darauf aufmerksam wurden.
Ich habe jetzt knapp
unter 800'000 Follower auf YouTube.
Dann habe ich
noch einen zweiten Kanal,
auf dem ich knapp 100'000,
97'000 oder so, Follower habe.
Auf meinem zweiten Vlogging-Channel
habe ich auch Videos,
die nicht nur Beauty betreffen,
sondern auch ganz andere Themen.
Auf Facebook habe ich 250'000.
Auf Twitter sind es 57'000.
Auf Instagram habe ich
nochmals etwa 55'000 Follower.
Mein Name ist Martin Faltl.
Ich bin Psychologe und arbeite
am Institut für Customer Insight
an der Universität St. Gallen
in der Forschung.
Wer heutzutage
mediale Reichweite aufbauen kann,
das hat sich fundamental verändert.
Früher war das
z.B. im Fall einer Band so,
dass man hobbymässig Musik machte,
bis ein Plattenlabel
gross promotete.
Das Plattenlabel entschied, wer
würdig war, Zuschauer zu haben.
Heute kann jeder versuchen,
Reichweite aufzubauen
und seine Inhalte zu vertreiben.
Das hat sich radikal geändert.
Dadurch gibt es viel mehr kleinere
Sender in den Sozialen Netzwerken
und natürlich auch
unglaublich viele Empfänger.
Im Vergleich zu früher gibt es
viel mehr Sender mittlerer Grösse.
In seiner Forschungsarbeit
untersucht Martin Faltl
die zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen
auf Social Media.
und deren Auswirkungen
auf das Konsumverhalten.
Was eine Kaufentscheidung
beeinflusst,
ist ein sehr komplexes
psychologisches Phänomen.
Das gibt es keine Antworten,
die man in einem Satz geben kann.
Wichtig ist aber,
dass wir demjenigen vertrauen,
der uns eine Empfehlung gibt, darum
geht's beim Influencer-Marketing.
Das ist ein wichtiger Faktor.
Telefonrechnung, Mahnung.
Was ist das?
Für meine Fans
mache ich ein Verlosungsvideo.
Ich gehe mit den Gewinnern
in den EuropaPark.
Ich schalte es heute um 12 Uhr
auf Instagram online.
* Seltsame elektronische Klänge *
Wow!
Wo bin ich hier gelandet?
Ist das - nicht der EuropaPark?
Okay, ich darf zehn Tickets verlosen
für einen Tag im EuropaPark.
Und es geht alles auf seine
Rechnung, d.h.: alles gratis.
Du kannst mitmachen, indem du
deine Begleitung markierst.
Ich rechne
mit Hunderttausenden von Views,
mit Tausenden von Kommentaren,
weil jeder bei einem solchen
Erlebnis dabei sein will.
Mein Name ist Manuel Nappo.
Ich bin Leiter des Center
für Digital Business an der HWZ,
der Hochschule für Wirtschaft
in Zürich.
Social Media
sind deshalb so erfolgreich,
weil sie ein menschliches Bedürfnis
befriedigen.
Der Mensch will
mit anderen Menschen verbunden sein,
will wissen,
was andere Menschen so machen,
was sein Netzwerk,
seine Freunde so machen.
Das stellt uns Social Media
zur Verfügung,
einfach in einer digitalen Form.
Und das ist natürlich
einfacher zu konsumieren
als die Live-Version.
Influencer im Marketing -
das gab es schon immer.
Sie hatten früher
einfach einen anderen Namen.
Z.B. Roger Federer
oder George Clooney,
die Werbung machen,
sind auch eine Form von Influencer.
Sie werden nicht gewählt,
weil sie Fachwissen haben,
weil sie etwas
von Kaffeemaschinen verstehen,
sondern weil sie
etwas repräsentieren:
Ihrem Anspruch an Qualität
wird geglaubt.
Das kann man runterdeklinieren
vom Testimonial zum Ambassador,
das war in den letzten zehn Jahren
ebenfalls ein Thema.
Jetzt ist es der Influencer,
von dem man sich verspricht,
dass er auf Social Media,
in seiner Community,
die er sich selbst aufgebaut hat,
wo er eine Kredibilität geniesst,
die Marke repräsentieren kann,
dass er für diese Marke
Werbung machen kann.
Deshalb hat es
in letzter Zeit so angezogen.
Wird heute
ein neues Kleidergeschäft eröffnet,
werden selbstverständlich Influencer
aus dem Lifestyle-Bereich eingeladen.
Als Gegenleistung
berichten diese dann auf ihren
sozialen Kanälen über den Anlass.
Die Schweizer Schauspielerin
Zoe Pastell
wird zu Modeschauen
auf der ganzen Welt eingeladen.
Die 18-Jährige hat 162'000 Follower,
mit denen sie ihre Erlebnisse teilt.
Mit 14 oder so eröffnete ich
einen Instagram-Account.
Vorher war ich auf
Facebook und anderen Plattformen
wie z.B. ASKfm,
auf der mir Leute Fragen
stellen konnten und ich antwortete.
Es begann schon megafrüh.
Dann kam Instragram auf.
Dort habe ich mir
auch ein Profil erstellt
und postete private Fotos
aus den Ferien, was auch immer.
Ich begann
immer öfter Dinge zu posten,
die mir einfach Spass gemacht haben.
Und dann steckt auch immer
ein Perfektionismus dahinter.
Ich will,
dass es megaperfekt aussieht.
Weil es mir irgendwie
viel Spass macht,
eine Welt in nur einem Bild
zu kreieren.
Bonjour! Ich habe ein Problem,
das ihr alle bestimmt auch kennt:
trockene Lippen.
Ihr mögt mich vielleicht
für verrückt erklären,
denn ich benutze Coconut Oil
praktisch für alles,
sei es Abschminken, Kochen,
Gesicht eincremen,
Beine eincremen, everything.
Und ich vergass, zu erwähnen,
dass ihr mit meinem
eingeblendeten Rabatt-Code
15 % auf das ganze Sortiment habt.
Ja, so hat das angefangen.
Ich wusste nicht,
wohin es mich führen würde.
Ich begann, jeden Tag
etwas zu posten, weil ich merkte:
"Okay, es kommt gut an,
wenn ich täglich poste."
"Es bewirkt etwas."
Deshalb integrierte ich es
in meinen Alltag.
Und ich habe erst
vor etwa eineinhalb Jahren
wirklich begonnen,
darauf zu arbeiten.
In den meisten Fällen
arbeite ich mit dem Brand zusammen,
der einen Event organisiert,
sei das ein Frühstück oder
ein Shooting oder was auch immer.
Ich will
verschiedene Messages verbreiten.
Eine davon ist eben:
Man darf träumen,
muss aber etwas dafür tun.
Macht das!
Wenn ihr etwas wollt, macht das!
Und glaubt daran, dass es klappt.
Kopiert nicht!
Lasst euch von
verschiedenen Dingen inspirieren,
aber kopiert nicht.
Was ich mir im Moment erhoffe, was
morgen komplett anders sein kann,
ist, dass ich als Schauspielerin
Fuss gefasst habe.
Es ist mir eigentlich egal wo,
aber dass ich weiterhin ...
immer noch die Möglichkeit habe,
eine Community zu haben.
Die virtuelle Community
ist die eigentliche Währung.
Je mehr Follower,
desto mehr Einfluss.
Die Influencer
mit der grössten Gefolgschaft
werden denn auch von Agenten
und Vermittlungsagenturen umgarnt.
Es herrscht Goldgräberstimmung.
Um die lukrativsten Geschäftsfelder
wird gekämpft.
Wir haben Influencer
aus der ganzen Schweiz eingeladen,
solche, mit denen wir
zusammenarbeiten, aber auch andere.
Das Ziel des heutigen Abends ist,
dass sich diese Leute ausserhalb der
Social-Media-Kanäle kennenlernen.
um damit eine Brücke zu schlagen
zwischen Digital- und Real-Life.
Wer heute ein Produkt oder
eine Dienstleistung kaufen will,
informiert sich
vorgängig im Internet,
nutzt immer häufiger das Smartphone
für die Recherche.
Waren es früher
persönliche Empfehlungen,
sind es heute
die Posts von Influencern,
die unser Kaufverhalten beeinflussen.
Ein guter Influencer ist ein Mensch,
der authentisch ist,
der einfach sein Leben lebt,
der Produkte,
Dienstleistungen und Botschaften
in seinen Alltag integriert,
und das über seine Kanäle
widerspiegelt
und gegen aussen kommuniziert.
Schliesslich folgen einem
Leute nur dann,
wenn man spannenden Content bringt.
D.h., dass man ein Thema
sehr genau besetzen muss
und gute Sachen über diesen Kanal
rausspielen kann - Tag für Tag.
Wenn du einmal Follower hast,
musst du sie unterhalten,
sonst springen sie wieder ab.
Da besteht nicht nur grosser Druck,
sondern auch eine Verantwortung.
Wenn man einmal
100'000-200'000 Follower hat,
kommt auch eine Verantwortung auf.
Dessen muss man sich bewusst sein,
gerade wenn junge Leute so viel
Verantwortung in die Hand bekommen.
Sie müssen sich daran gewöhnen,
damit umzugehen.
Das - und diesen Kessel da.
Von diesem sozialen Druck ist
bei der Kite-Surferin Manuela Jungo
wenig zu spüren.
Die ehemalige Marketingfachfrau
geniesst ihren Erfolg,
oder wie es Surfer ausdrücken würden:
Sie reitet die Welle
und verdient damit gutes Geld.
Dort sieht es schön aus.
Ich startete meine Reise 2010.
2012 fuhr ich
die World Tour im Kitesurfen mit.
Seitdem ist das mein Leben:
draussen sein, kiten,
Stand-up Paddling, biken.
Und mittlerweile
generiere ich immer mehr
Content für verschiedene Brands.
Ausgerüstet
mit professionellem Equipment
suchen Manuela und ihr Partner James
nach einer geeigneten Location
für das heutige Shooting.
Das ist nicht möglich dort oben.
- From the top.
Wie willst du mich dort
fotografieren, wie ich Salat esse?
But if you're on the top,
you look down on the ...
Denkst du, das sieht gut aus?
Es ist viel zu windig.
Wir haben jetzt
eine Location gefunden,
aber leider ist es
etwas windig und bewölkt.
Aber wir hoffen,
es sieht trotzdem gut aus.
Jetzt muss ich erst alles aufbauen.
Danach bereite ich
ein kleines Picknick vor.
Ich hoffe, dass es gut aussieht.
Vor wenigen Jahren
wäre für ein Werbeshooting
eine Agentur beauftragt worden.
Dank neuster Technologie
entstehen die Bilder heute
weniger aufwendig im Zweierteam.
* Elektronische Popmusik *
Ich habe Einnahmequellen
an verschiedenen Orten.
Ich habe Sponsoren, mit denen ich
sehr eng zusammenarbeite.
Ich weiss viel über die Firma,
über ihre neuen Produkte.
Ich habe immer
ein paar Uhren mit dabei,
die ich je nach Aktivität platziere.
Oder eine Uhr alleine -
ich muss nicht immer im Bild sein.
Oftmals ist es nur meine Hand,
die im Bild ist.
Ich arbeite auch
mit Agenturen zusammen.
Der Brand geht zur Agentur und sagt:
"Das ist das Produkt, das ist
die Idee, die wir vertreten wollen."
Dann stellt die Agentur dem Brand
verschiedene Influencer
zur Verfügung, also zur Auswahl.
Dann wählen sie aus:
"Es ist cool, was Manuela macht."
"Sie ist draussen."
"Wir wollen diesen
aktiven Fitness-Lifestyle."
Dann geben sie mir ein Produkt,
sagen mir,
welche Hashtags ich brauchen soll
und wie das Foto aussehen soll.
Manchmal mache ich auch Vorschläge:
"Das würde ich gerne tun."
"Seid ihr einverstanden? Passt das?"
"Soll ich euch das Foto schicken,
bevor ich es poste?"
Es gibt verschiedene Formen
der Zusammenarbeit.
Haben Manuela und James
ein gutes Bild inszeniert,
wird es auf ihren
Instagram Account geladen
und mit den entsprechenden
Hashtags versehen.
Diese wiederum sind
mit den Sponsoren verlinkt.
Klicken Follower
auf den entsprechenden Link,
landen sie automatisch
auf dem Kanal des Sponsors.
Der Werbekreis ist geschlossen.
Das Erfolgsgeheimnis ist simpel:
Zeigt Manuela ihren rund 27'000 Fans
ein Produkt in einem Instagram-Bild,
macht sie damit
eine unterschwellige Empfehlung,
die von ihren Followern als
Tipp einer Freundin empfunden wird
und nicht als plumpe Werbung.
Doch nicht klar
deklarierte Empfehlungen
gelten als Schleichwerbung.
Es ist natürlich interessanter,
wenn der Kollege sagt:
"Dieses Produkt finde ich lässig."
Das hat für den Empfänger
der Botschaft eine andere Qualität,
als wenn er sagen würde:
"Ich wurde bezahlt,
um dir dieses Angebot zu empfehlen."
So gesehen sehe ich die Verlockung,
zu versuchen,
solche Empfehlungen als nicht
kommerziell erscheinen zu lassen.
Wir als Content-Creators oder
Influencers, wie man uns nennt,
machen das Ganze etwas menschlicher.
Wir sind ganz normale Menschen
wie alle anderen.
Das ist genau, was Menschen wollen:
Sie wollen reale Gesichter
hinter den Kulissen.
Dadurch haben sie
einen Kontakt zu mir.
Sie können sich mit mir austauschen,
mir auf Twitter schreiben,
mir auf Instagram folgen und gucken,
was ich sonst noch mache.
Das macht es realer, als wenn
man eine Empfehlung bekommt.
Das ist, als ob man
eine Empfehlung oder einen Tipp
von einer Freundin bekommen.
Das ist der Grund, wieso dieses
Phänomen Influencer so stark wächst
und auch so erfolgreich ist.
Bei der Schweizerischen
Lauterkeitskommission
gibt es bereits einen Grundsatz.
Sie hat ihre Praxis, ihre
Auslegung des Lauterkeitsrechts,
in sog. Grundsätze verfasst.
Im Rahmen dieses Büchleins
gibt es einen Grundsatz zur
Trennung und klaren Erkennbarkeit
von kommerzieller Kommunikation.
Und das ist
medienneutral formuliert,
gilt also auch
für Social-Media-Kanäle.
Ich habe vor einigen Jahren
mit Transparenz angefangen,
weil mir sehr wichtig ist,
dass meine Zuschauerinnen wissen,
ob es ein gekauftes Produkt ist
oder nicht,
ob es mir zugeschickt wurde
oder nicht.
Weil mir wichtig war,
das mitzuteilen, fing ich an,
diese Unboxing-Videos zu machen,
in denen ich zeige,
was mir alles zugeschickt wird.
Das ist nicht unbedingt,
um mich gross rauszustellen:
"Wow! Ich bin so cool.
Guck mal, was ich alles bekomme!"
Sondern eher,
damit diese Transparenz da ist.
Eine interessante Gruppe:
Perlen des Influencer-Marketings.
Auf diesem Portal werden etwas gar
oberflächliche oder künstliche Posts
etwas auf die Schippe genommen.
Und es wird jeweils
auch die Frage gestellt,
welchen Wert das für das werbe-
treibende Unternehmen haben soll,
das dies doch immerhin bezahlt hat.
Jeder kann Beschwerde einreichen.
Die Lauterkeitskommission prüft
nicht, ob man ein Interesse hat.
Man muss
nicht direkt betroffen sein.
Es braucht eine Beschwerde, damit
die Kommission einen Fall beurteilt.
In diesem Sinn kann jedermann
eine Beschwerde einreichen,
man muss nicht einmal
persönlich von Posts genervt sein.
Man muss einfach eine Beschwerde
vollständig ausfüllen,
dann ist das Verfahren
in Gang gebracht.
Mein Name ist Francesco Giammarco.
Ich bin freier Journalist
in Hamburg.
Und ich habe für einen Artikel
in "Die Zeit" versucht,
Influencer zu werden.
Vier Wochen lang
habe ich mich fotografiert,
oder fotografieren lassen.
Habe meine Freundin
instrumentalisiert,
um Fotos von mir zu machen,
habe mir den Hund meiner Schwester
ausgeliehen,
um Beliebtheit im Internet
zu erlangen.
Ich versuchte, Influencer zu werden.
So richtig gut
hat das Ganze nicht geklappt.
Nicht ganz ernst gemeint
war der Selbstversuch
des 32-jährigen Journalisten.
Das Ziel seines Experiments:
talentfrei schnell berühmt
und reich werden.
Dann ging ich zum Friseur und sagte:
"Ich hätte gerne eine Frisur
wie ein Influencer."
Denn vorher
waren die Haare ungefähr so,
also nicht sehr tauglich.
Aber das verstand die arme Friseurin
überhaupt nicht
und fragte:
"Wie sieht so ein Influencer aus?"
Ich wusste es auch nicht genau.
Dann machte sie mir die Frisur,
die jeder, die jedes Mitglied der
Deutschen Nationalmannschaft hat:
oben etwas mehr
und auf der Seite weg.
Dieses System
des Folgens und Gefolgtwerdens
folgt seinen eigenen Regeln.
Es gibt z.B. den Hashtag
#followforfollow.
D.h., wenn man seine Inhalte
mit diesem Hashtag versieht,
dann kommuniziert man:
"Wenn ihr mir folgt,
folge ich euch zurück."
Weil die Anzahl der Follower -
zumindest in der Theorie -
die Währung ist, tauscht man
die Währung gegeneinander aus:
Dann habe ich einen Follower mehr
und du hast einen Follower mehr.
Das System funktioniert nur
für den Bodensatz von Instagram,
aber dann war ich
mindestens im Bodensatz drin.
Vorher war ich gar
nicht in der Nahrungskette,
und dann war ich ganz unten.
Als ich mir
1'000 Kontakte erkauft hatte,
konnte ich mich
auf dieser Plattform anmelden
und konnte mich
für verschiedene Produkte bewerben.
Hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Ich hatte ein Angebot:
Ein Unternehmen antwortete positiv
auf meine Bewerbung als Influencer.
Sie stellten Sexspielzeuge her.
Sie wollten Vibratoren vermarkten,
aber als sie dann ...
Die sagten erst Ja,
dann aber analysierten sie
mein Profil und sahen,
dass ich, das sieht man deutlich
am Verlauf der Followerzahlen,
offensichtlich
gekaufte Follower hatte.
Und dann zogen sie es zurück.
Wahrscheinlich wollten sie ihr
qualitativ hochwertiges Produkt,
was es, glaub ich, war,
nicht beschmutzen,
indem sie einen Fake-Influencer
für ihren Vibrator benutzen.
Kann ich auch verstehen.
Der Preis. Du sagst uns,
wie viel du verdienen möchtest.
Wir können dir eigentlich
nur eine Empfehlung abgeben,
was der Markt bereit ist,
für dein Profil zu zahlen.
Aber ich denke,
da finden wir uns meistens auch.
Ja, das sowieso.
Die erste Messgrösse ist in
der Regel die Bruttoreichweite:
Wie viele Follower
hat ein Influencer
auf all seinen Kanälen
zusammengezählt?
Wir können dem Kunden ausweisen,
wie viele Views dieser Post hatte.
Wenn ein Follower eine längere Zeit
auf einem Influencer-Post verweilt,
geht es in ein Engagement über.
Das Höchste der Gefühle
in der Schweiz ist,
wenn ein Follower
den Post des Influencers shared,
d.h., auf seinen eigenen Kanälen
weiter teilt.
Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl,
dass das ganze Thema Influencer
erst letztes Jahr
so richtig aufgekommen ist.
Weil vor fünf Jahren,
als ich angefangen habe,
hat man die "Künstler"
gar nicht so richtig wahrgenommen,
auf Facebook und Instagram
und keine Ahnung wo noch.
Es waren mehr die Promis,
die man wahrgenommen hat,
mehr Zeitungs-,
Radio- und Fernsehwerbung.
Erst seit letztem Jahr
ist es so richtig im Kommen.
Ich finde den Fakt noch spannend,
dass zum ersten Mal,
seit es Medien gibt,
ein privater Mensch die Power hat,
irgendetwas zu verbreiten -
und hat dazu einen eigenen Kanal.
Bei allen anderen Medien,
bei den herkömmlichen Medien
war das nicht möglich.
Bevor es Social Media gab,
war das gar nicht möglich.
Das ist ein megaspannender Fakt.
Wir Influencer diskutieren,
ob es das in fünf Jahren noch gibt.
Ich mag mich an eine Zeit erinnern,
in der Leute sagten:
"Social Media oder Facebook ist
ein Hype, der wieder verschwindet."
Leider nicht.
Es wird Social Media geben,
solange es Menschen geben wird.
Menschen interessiert,
was andere tun.
Viele Menschen haben
per se einen Darstellungsdrang.
D.h., dass diese Plattformen
nicht so einfach totzukriegen sind.
Also: Influencer gleich Virus?
Uns wird es immer geben.
Kann man irgendwie auch so sagen.
Welche Jobs stehen bei dir an?
Was ist dein nächstes,
grösseres Projekt?
Jetzt mache ich mit EuropaPark ...
Mit zehn Fans gehe ich dorthin.
- Jawohl.
Es ist eine ziemlich geile Sache,
den Fans etwas zurückzugeben.
Jawohl, d.h., du besuchst
mit Ihnen den EuropaPark
und sie dürfen den Tag
mit dir verbringen. - Genau.
Ich finde es megaspannend,
wenn Offline-Komponenten
und Interaktionen mit Followern
dabei sind.
Das hört sich toll an.
Jetzt habe ich für den EuropaPark
ein Verlosungsvideo gedreht,
das ich heute
um 12 Uhr online stelle,
über den Sonntagmittag.
Jetzt sitze ich hier
gerade in einem Restaurant,
nicht so wie erwartet
zu Hause am Laptop,
sondern wirklich draussen,
mobil unterwegs,
stelle ich meine Posts online.
Schnell lesen, ob alles stimmt.
Am Sonntag um 12 Uhr mittags sind
die meisten Jugendlichen wach.
Das Erste, was sie tun, ist,
auf das Handy zu schauen.
Und dann geht es los mit Liken
und Markieren und Kommentieren.
Jetzt teile ich es.
Nach 30 Sek. habe ich
schon 100 Likes, kann man sagen.
Da! Jetzt läuft's! Nach 3 Min.
habe ich schon 160 Kommentare.
Nach 3 Min.! Jetzt stelle ich noch
eine vorproduzierte Story online.
Jetzt stelle ich es auf Swissmeme,
wo ich 500'000 habe,
um es anzuteasen.
Bei diesem Gewinnspiel
geht es darum,
dass man einen Freund markiert,
den man bei diesem Erlebnis
gerne dabeihätte.
Jetzt habe ich
schon 1'000 Kommentare.
Das ist überwältigend,
wirklich krass!
Nach 7 Min. 1'000 Kommentare!
Das ist eben so eine Möglichkeit
statt ihnen irgendwie Sachen zu ver-
losen wie drei Hautcremes oder so,
gehe ich mit ihnen
lieber in den EuropaPark.
Dann haben wirklich alle
etwas davon.
Mit diesen Posts
gibt es etwas Taschengeld.
Mit diesem Post könnte ich
jetzt z.B. meine Miete zahlen.
Ich könnte mir etwas leisten,
Kleider kaufen,
aber trotzdem
habe ich immer im Hinterkopf:
Ich lebe noch immer in der Schweiz.
Ich will arbeiten.
Und es soll ein Hobby bleiben.
Darum will ich mich finanziell
nicht allzu stark darauf verlassen.
Und ich für meinen Teil
mache das nebenbei.
Ich mache das als Hobby,
weil es mir Spass macht.
Sobald Spass und Druck
zusammenkommen,
stimmt irgendetwas nicht.
Jetzt, nach 30 Min.,
habe ich 24'000 Aufrufe
und schon fast 5'000 Kommentare.
Es ist krass,
wie die Leute da abgehen.
Das ist mega.
In der Schweiz
sieht man das so gut wie gar nie,
also dass es jemand
in der Schweiz schafft,
nur mit Schweizer Followern.
Wenn ich die Fans privat kenne,
schreibe ich ihnen meistens zurück,
ich probier's.
Aber auf Kommentare zu reagieren,
dauert manchmal ewig.
Nachher stellt jemand anders
noch eine Frage,
dann erhält man auf die Antwort
eine Antwort und dann ...
Ja, und das ist
das Leben als Influencers.
Die Beziehung eines Followers
zu seinem Social-Media-Star
oder Influencer
nennt die Wissenschaft parasozial.
D.h., dass die Beziehung
einseitig ist,
Informationen werden
nur in eine Richtung verteilt.
Influencer sind für Follower
zwar halbwegs erreichbar,
manchmal kriegen Follower
einen Kommentar zurück,
aber in der Regel produziert
der Influencer die Inhalte
und der Follower verfolgt sie.
Dieses Phänomen
nennt man parasoziale Beziehung.
Ob Social Media
und der Konsum von idealen
Darstellungen des Lebens anderer
glücklich macht,
ist ein heisses Forschungsthema.
Studien deuten darauf hin, dass es
durchaus unglücklich machen kann,
gerade wenn man nicht in einer
guten psychischen Konstitution ist.
Wir sehen nur idealisierte
Ausschnitte aus dem Leben anderer,
aber deren Straucheln
sehen wir nicht.
* Treibende Popmusik *
* Musik stoppt abrupt. *
Wir starteten die Kampagne
Echtes Leben vor zwei Jahren.
Da ging es sozusagen
um dieses Thema.
Wir wollten darauf hinweisen, dass
das Leben nicht nur daraus besteht,
an einem Strand
mit kristallklarem Meer
mit dem Jetski im Sommer
gebräunt unter Palmen zu liegen,
sondern dass Leben
viel mehr bedeutet.
Für die meisten Jugendlichen
und für die Erwachsenen,
bedeutet das Leben: in die Schule
gehen, arbeiten, Alltag erledigen,
gewisse Sachen klappen nicht,
gewisse Misserfolge
gehören auch dazu.
Der Einfluss von Social Media
auf unser Leben
beschäftigt Forschung und Wirtschaft
gleichermassen.
Eltern und Lehrerschaft
wiederum fragen sich,
ob Social Media,
ob zu viel Internetkonsum
die heutige Jugend gefährdet.
Laurent Sedano von der Pro Juvente
kennt das Medienverhalten
von Jugendlichen.
Das sind die Personen,
mit denen wir versucht haben,
die Jugendlichen künstlich
in diese Situation zu versetzen,
wie es ist, wenn man
offensichtlichen Erfolg hat.
Wenn man jeden Tag auf Instagram ist
oder anderen sozialen Netzwerken,
sieht man immer,
welchen Erfolg die anderen haben,
und stellt dabei
ständig Vergleiche an.
Das kann je nachdem
Auswirkungen haben,
dass man sich weniger wertschätzt,
dass man in eine Depression fällt
und solche Sachen.
Der Druck, sich immer
von der besten Seite zu zeigen,
ist auch für Influencer enorm.
Dem australischen Model
Essena O" Neill wurde alles zu viel.
Sie machte ihren Zusammenbruch
öffentlich
und zog sich
aus den Social Media zurück.
Es gab eine, die ihr Profil
medial sehr aufwendig kündigte.
und auch Stellung dazu bezog.
Sie zeigte gewisse Fotos,
die sie gemacht hatte,
ein Strandfoto war auch mit dabei.
Sie fand, für dieses Foto habe sie
drei Tage fast nichts gegessen,
damit ihr Bauch
möglichst flach aussehe.
Und ihre Schwester sagte,
sie hätten 2'000 Fotos gemacht,
bis sie das Foto hatten,
von dem sie fanden:
"Das kann man posten."
Die ganze Arbeit dahinter
wird nicht sichtbar gemacht.
* Rockmusik: "Children
of the Revolution" von T. Rex *
Der intensive Konsum
von Social Media
hat vielerlei Einfluss
auf die Psyche junger Menschen.
Neue Studien zeigen, dass dadurch
oberflächlicheres Denken
oder oberflächlicheres
Sozialverhalten entsteht.
Andererseits kann das
auch sehr inspirierend sein.
Man kann auf Social Media
gute Vorbilder finden.
Man kann jede Menge Wissen
zu bestimmten Themen finden
und so in einem anderen Tempo
lernen, als das früher möglich war.
Wer von euch hat ein Handy,
mit dem er ins Internet gehen kann?
Also ein Smartphone.
Kinder wachsen in der Welt auf,
in der sie aufwachsen.
Sie lernen nur das kennen
und entwickeln dementsprechend
auch ...
entwickeln dementsprechend
auch Strategien,
wie sie
mit dieser Situation umgehen.
Und für uns Erwachsene
ist das oft so, dass wir finden:
"Okay, uns würde das stressen."
Aber sie haben vielleicht
ganz natürlich gelernt,
damit umzugehen.
Vielleicht können sie es
sogar positiv nutzen.
Ich glaube,
Gewisse haben damit ein Problem,
aber das war bei uns auch so.
Mit der Situation, mit der wir als
Jugendliche konfrontiert waren,
konnten einige besser umgehen
als andere.
Wer von euch hat Instagram?
Alle ausser zwei Schülern.
Okay, ihr dürft euch wieder setzen.
Wer von euch kann erklären,
was das ist?
Jeffrey.
Man uploaded Fotos auf Instagram.
Und deine Freunde sehen das.
Damit zeigt man: "Das war cool."
Man will zeigen, was man getan hat.
Wie kannst du den anderen auch
zeigen, dass du etwas cool findest?
Indem ich ein Bild schicke.
Schicken. Und dann kann man
bei Instagram auch noch ...
Kommentieren.
- Kommentieren und ... Melissa?
Liken.
- Liken, genau.
Wir sind an einem Medienworkshop
namens Medienprofis,
der von Pro Juventute
angeboten wird.
Im Rahmen dieses Workshops thema-
tisieren wir verschiedene Themen,
die die Kinder anbelangen,
die sie beschäftigen.
Das kann das Thema Internet sein,
Social Media, YouTube,
eigentlich Verschiedenes,
das wir damit abholen,
und mit den Kindern besprechen.
Welche YouTuber kennt ihr?
Rotpilz, Rewinside,
Felix von der Laden
Paluten. - Katja Krasavice,
BibisBeautyPalace.
PewDiePie
- PrankBros - Spinus.
Laurette, Leon Machere, Mert Matan.
Kennt ihr auch
einen Schweizer YouTuber?
Aargauer Meme,
Ausländer Meme, Swissmeme.
Raffa's Plastic Life.
- Und Zekisworld.
Wer von euch weiss,
was ein Influencer ist?
Jemand, der kleine
oder grosse Kinder beeinflusst.
Ja, das ist
eigentlich ein Influencer,
übersetzt heisst das Beeinflusser.
Influencer sind Leute
wie Lisa und Lena,
die durch ihre Musik
berühmt geworden sind.
Sie beeinflussen Kinder.
Meist werden sie gesponsert,
z.B. von Adidas,
dann präsentieren sie
Adidas-Kleider.
Wenn ein Bild viele Likes hat,
erhalten sie dafür Geld.
Sie müssen Werbung
auch kennzeichnen.
Wenn du Hashtag Werbung siehst,
ist klar, dass es Werbung ist.
Transparenz ist ein grosses Thema
im Influencer-Marketing.
Wir unterschätzen
Jugendliche manchmal,
was ihre Sensibilität
für Werbemassnahmen angeht.
Zahlreiche Studien zeigen, dass
auch schon Kinder im Grundschulalter
sehr wohl in der Lage sind,
Überzeugungsversuche zu erkennen.
Die Regulierung
von staatlicher Seite her
hinkt dabei der Praxis
etwas hinterher,
holt aber nach und nach auf.
Das zeigt sich daran,
dass inzwischen
die Kennzeichnungspflichten
deutlich strenger sind
als am Anfang.
Schatz? - Ja?
- Komm bitte!
Schau mal, wie viele Views
ich auf diesem Video habe,
das ich gestern gepostet habe:
160'000.
Wow! Und wie viele Likes?
- 21'000.
Ja, ich habe wieder zugeschlagen.
Nicht schlecht, oder?
Ja, das ist toll.
Wie weit bist du mit dem Essen?
Soll ich helfen?
Es geht noch 20 Min.
Ich habe den Reis zu spät reingetan.
Geht es eigentlich noch?
Nein, das war nur Spass, easy.
Koch du selbst!
Du lässt mich ja nicht.
- Mit deinen Views.
Ich und meine Views.
Davon wird man leider nicht satt.
Babe, geht es bei dir?
Du könntest mir
jetzt dann echt helfen.
Okay.
Was brauchst du?
Du kannst schauen,
was als Nächstes kommt.
Das kann ich.
Die Anleitung lesen?
Das ist eben das Lustige:
Es heisst immer, Männer
würden nicht in der Küche helfen.
Aber sie lässt sich nicht helfen,
weil sie weiss,
dass es ausartet, wenn ich helfe.
Das kann
zu einer Katastrophe führen.
Er wollte mir einmal
einen Kaffee machen.
Danach war die Kaffeemaschine
kaputt. Nur einen Kaffee.
Das ist kein Scherz.
Das ist echt kein Witz,
das war echt so.
Innerhalb von 2 Min.
hat er das hinbekommen.
Und die Kaffeemaschine
hat echt nur zwei Knöpfe:
für grossen und kleinen Kaffee.
Also kann ich dir nicht helfen?
Doch, du kannst die Anleitung lesen
und mir sagen,
was als Nächstes kommt.
Wo ist mein Handy? - Dort.
Ich lese sie selbst und
schaue, was als Nächstes kommt.
Lass uns bei diesem Wetter
draussen chillen!
Und wie war dein Tag heute?
Gut. Und bei dir?
Super.
- Es war nichts Spezielles.
Ich denke, es kann gut oder
schlecht sein, es kommt darauf an,
wie man es nutzt.
Ich habe selbst einen Account
und versuche,
auch ein bisschen was zu posten,
aber mir ist es nicht so wichtig.
Es ist nicht mein Beruf,
mein Hauptberuf.
Ganz ehrlich:
Wenn ich das Ganze mit dem
Entertainment nicht gestartet hätte,
dann hätte ich auch kein Instagram.
Mich interessiert nicht,
ob Jessica oder Sarah heute Reis
isst und das postet.
Ich hoffe doch auch,
dass es dich nicht interessiert,
was Jessica für Sachen macht.
Oder ob Thomas heute zwei Bier
hatte, das kratzt mich nicht.
Wenn ich Werbung auf Facebook sehe,
reagiere ich gar nicht darauf.
Ja, voll.
Das ist sehr individuell, aber was
passiert, ist natürlich schon krass.
Dass sie unsere Daten klauen.
Und dann unseren Informationen
entsprechend Werbung aufschalten.
Ja, voll.
Ja, was soll man dazu sagen?
Es ist auch etwas scary,
dass das Internet genau weiss,
was wir gerne tun, was wir
gerne essen, was wir gerne trinken,
was wir suchen,
wohin wir gerne möchten,
welches unsere Träume sind.
Das ist schon unglaublich.
Wir geben so viel preis.
Jeder muss selbst entscheiden,
wie viel er online sein will
oder nicht.
Ich habe mir Grenzen gesetzt
und gesagt:
"Das ist privat. Das muss ich
nicht mit der grossen Welt teilen."
Aber andere Leute denken,
dass sie desto erfolgreicher werden,
je mehr sie posten.
Vielleicht können sie
deshalb nicht abschalten.
Eine neue Welt ist aufgegangen.
Gewisse Sachen sind noch immer so,
wie sie wahrscheinlich immer waren.
Und gewisse Sachen
sind hinzugekommen,
z.B. wie man alles filmt.
Ja, es gibt positive
und negative Aspekte des Ganzen.
Oscar Wilde sagte,
Mode sei so hässlich, man müsse sie
alle sechs Monate erneuern.
Das Gleiche gilt für das Marketing,
das so langweilig ist,
dass man sich alle sechs Monate
etwas Neues ausdenken muss,
das die Kunden wieder begeistert.
Der nächste Hype
wartet schon vor der Tür.
* Rocksong: "Children
of the Recolution" von T. Rex *
Die Produktplatzierung
oder Werbemassnahmen,
die heute dem Begriff
Influencer-Marketing
fast eine
negative Konnotation verleihen,
werden sich dahingehend verändern,
dass sie souveräner
in Inhalte eingebettet werden,
dass Überzeugungsversuche
nicht mehr so plump gestaltet sind.
Es gibt in jedem Beruf
Gutes und Schlechtes.
Influencer - klar,
du kannst das grosse Geld machen,
aber die Frage ist nachher:
zu welchem Preis?
"Die Jugend" gibt es nicht.
Es gibt aber Erwachsene, die
vergessen, wie es ist, jung zu sein.
Lustig ist,
dass heute schon 18-Jährige
sich über die heutige Jugend
auslassen.
Die Abstände werden immer kürzer.
Man blickt immer zurück.
Das hat sehr oft
mit Unverständnis zu tun.
Die Aufgabe der Erwachsenen ist,
sich vorzustellen
was die Jugendlichen machen.
Dann merken sie, dass es eigentlich
noch immer das Gleiche ist,
dass die Jugend, die wir haben,
ganz okay ist.